[Music]  to my right is bounty law series lead  and jake cahill himself rick dalton and  to my left is rick stunt double cliff  booth so Rick explain to the audience  exactly what it is a stunt double does  actors are required to do a lot of  dangerous stuff cliff here is meant to  help carry the load is that how you  describe your job cliff  carrying his load adds about right  [Music]  my hands are registered as lethal  weapons we get into a fight  I accidentally kill you I go to jail  anybody accidentally kills anybody in a  fight they go to jail  it's called manslaughter  [Music]  [Music]  that was the best acting I've ever seen  in my whole life thank you  [Music]  [Music]